hello everyone welcome to an
introduction to object-oriented
programming
in this course we will be getting into
what object-oriented programming means
as well as going over its four main
principles
this course will assume that you have
some knowledge of programming before
hopping in
if that's not the case i would suggest
checking out our introduction to
programming video
which will be linked in the description
that video will give you information on
the basics of programming
that are necessary to be able to
understand more advanced topics
such as those covered in this video for
this lecture
we will be exploring object-oriented
programming in a manner that will be
applicable for its use
in any programming language in which it
is supported
examples will be used to explain the
concept being discussed
however they will be explained well
enough that specific knowledge of the
language being used in the example will
not be necessary
with that being said let's get into it
in this first section we will be going
over
what object oriented programming
actually is
in order to understand what
object-oriented programming is
it's best to first understand what
objects are
and in order to do that it's best to
first understand what primitive data
types are
so let's start there primitive data
types are exactly what they sound like
variables that store single simple
values
examples of such primitive types are the
byte
int float double boolean
and char these primitive types
only act to store a single piece of data
of a certain kind
and for a while when programming was
still developing
this was just fine many programs being
written at the time
weren't complex by today's standards
thus
programmers could get away with only
using these primitive types
however as programs became larger and
more complex primitive data types
weren't really cutting it anymore
programmers began to want to group
variables of similar type together
why would this be useful well to serve
as an example
let's imagine you are trying to program
a chess game
when programming a knight into the game
there are plenty of variables that you
will need
in order for the piece to work how it
should for example
you would need a position variable to
keep track of where the knight is
additionally you would need a boolean to
represent whether the piece has been
captured or not
because if it has you would not want it
to show up
nor should you be able to move with it
you may also need a variable to
represent which
color the knight is so that the game can
treat it correctly
these are just a few of the variables
that you would need for one piece
and you would need one of each of these
variables for each piece on the board
each of which would contain different
data clearly
it would be easiest if you could group
all of the variables related to
say one of your knights together
so that you may deal with them as one
entity
additionally you may want to group your
two knights together
as they behave similarly you then may
want to group the pieces of each side
together
as they would be treated differently in
reference to each other
in essence grouping related variables
together
is almost necessary when it comes to
complex programs
this is where the struct or structure
came in
in c the structure is similar to an
array
if you don't know what an array is i'd
suggest you check out
either our introduction to programming
course for an overview
or our data structure series for a more
in-depth look
at both arrays and many other data
structures
both arrays and structures allow the
programmer to store
several pieces of data together however
structures vary from arrays
in that structures allow the programmer
to store data of different types
together
for instance whereas an array would
allow you to store only ins
or only strings using a structure you
could store ins and strings together
along with other data types a structure
can even store other structures within
it
a structure can be very useful in the
earlier chess example
because you could store all of the
useful pieces of data related to the
knight
in one structure that represents that
you could then store your knight
structures together in one structure
that represents all of the knights
and so on the structure allowed such
grouping to take place beyond what
arrays were capable of
the structure is in many ways the
precursor to the object
which of course object-oriented
programming is oriented around
the main issue with using a structure in
this way and an issue that objects would
come to remedy
was that you could not define functions
within a structure you could only
reference them
when object-oriented programming came
along objects allowed you to store data
of all kinds together
and additionally define and store
functions
now before we go much further i should
get into exactly what objects are
objects are instances of a class and a
class
is basically a template for an object
this may seem like a circular way of
looking at these concepts
but allow me to explain let's say i
define a night class
in this class i would define and store
data that is common of all
knights this would be mainly the way
that knights are able to move
thus in this class i would define a
function that uses the knight's current
position
to return squares that the knight can
move to
i may also define a position variable
as well as a color variable but i would
not initialize them
when it comes to specific things such as
variables that each object under the
class
in this case each night would have
different data for
it's best to define them when i create
the object rather than in the class
itself
for instance each of the four knights
that begin in a game of chess
start on different squares than one
another
initializing the position variable in
the night class
would imply that you want each night
object created from this class
to begin with the same position which
you do not
however each of the knights would behave
the same
in terms of the squares it could move to
based on their position
and thus it is best to define a move
function in the class
rather than repeating the same function
definition in each object that i create
when creating a night object you
initialize its attributes
or its variables and its methods or its
functions
to contain information specific to that
night
whereas the night class represents any
given night
a night object represents one night in
particular
essentially object oriented programming
is the best tool us programmers have
right now to create complex programs by
grouping together related data and
functions
throughout the course of this video we
are going to be getting into detail into
how all of this works
using the four main principles of object
object-oriented programming
those being encapsulation abstraction
inheritance and polymorphism
this next section is going to be
focusing on the first of the four main
principles
of object-oriented programming
encapsulation
encapsulation refers to bundling data
along with methods that can operate on
that data
within a class essentially
it is the idea of hiding data within a
class that anything outside that class
cannot directly interact with that is
not to say that they are unable to
interact with the separate object's
attributes at all however
instead members of other classes looking
to
interact with the attributes of an
object should only be able to do so
through that class's methods in practice
one way this tends to work is by
creating getting
and setting methods these methods act to
either get information from an object
or set attributes to different values
for instance
think back to the chess example from the
previous section
if i was moving one piece and i wanted
to determine whether it was able to
capture another piece
i would need to define a dot get method
associated with each piece
that returns the piece's color in this
case piece dot get color
this way i could check the color of any
piece
from anywhere in my code without having
to access the internal attributes of
said pieces
this allows us to retrieve the
information from where it is defined
additionally this makes it easiest to
keep track of attributes
that depend on one another for example
if i was programming a game i may have
two different attributes for the
player's health
max health and current health
when the character levels up i may have
their max health increase as well
when this happens i would want the
current health to be set to the maximum
health
instead of changing both of these values
directly
i can define the set max health method
such that the current health
is also set to the maximum health once
the maximum health has increased
furthermore these setting methods allow
values to be validated
for instance if current health is not
able to exceed maximum health
then i would have the set current health
method check if current health would be
greater to maximum health
before making the change
finally you may want some values to be
read only from outside a class
which means you would only define a
getter method and not
a center method for another example
let's look back at chess when dealing
with a piece's position
you would want to keep track of its rank
or its row
and its file or its column
when the piece moves you may think it
would be okay to just set
piece.rank and piece.file to new values
however as discussed above this is not
the best way to handle it
it would be better to define a pst.move
function that takes the intended new
position
and checks if that is indeed a valid
move the piece would not be able to move
if
say the new location is off the board a
piece of the same color is already on
that square
or making such a move would put the king
of the same color in check
additionally other methods may be called
from this move method
for instance one that captures an enemy
piece if it was on that square
or one that puts the enemy king in check
were the pieces attributes just to be
directly changed
you could end up in a strange situation
where illegal moves are played
and pieces occupy the same square
essentially
getter methods allowing validation can
be very useful
encapsulation is useful for a variety of
reasons
as we just went over it is best to not
allow
anything external to directly edit an
object's attributes
this is especially true when working on
large and complex programs
where you may want individual pieces of
the program to work well
without requiring them to rely on every
other section of the code
in this way preventing each piece of
your code
from referencing and requiring knowledge
of the inner workings of each other
section of code
is very important to keep your program
from becoming completely entangled
in itself this is an idea we will touch
upon
in future sections to come but for now
it's best to understand
that information hiding that is keeping
one class from being able to directly
access the data of another class
is important to keep control of your
program and reducing its overall
complexity
overall encapsulation is a vital
component of object oriented programming
that allows the programmer to maintain
control of their data
and to keep their program from ending up
in any unwanted states
in this next section we are going to be
discussing the next of the four main
principles of object-oriented
programming
abstraction abstraction refers to the
idea of only showing essential details
and hiding everything else this idea is
present in everyday life
when you drive your car there are some
things you need to understand about
you need to understand how the steering
wheel steers the car
and how the gas and brake pedals work
you also need to know how much gas your
car has
and that it needs gas to work these are
necessary details for you to be able to
drive the car
properly however the exact way that the
car works internally
isn't something that most people need to
concern themselves with
how the gas reacts in the engine and how
that translates into the car
moving forward really isn't important
while you are driving your car
all that matters is that you know it
will work this way
whoever built the car had to worry about
how exactly the car would work
so that you don't have to this idea
extends to object oriented programming
the classes you create should act like
your car
users of your classes should not worry
about the exact inner details of
said classes this idea is similar to
that of encapsulation that we discussed
in the previous section
earlier we mentioned how you should not
have classes directly interact with the
data stored within other classes
rather have them use the class's methods
to access their data
this idea is especially important when
you want to work on your program
incrementally where you focus on one
class at a time
and ensure that it works this is a very
useful approach
as it can be difficult for you to focus
in the big picture while programming
and splitting up your project into
smaller chunks can make it much more
manageable
furthermore programs nowadays are vast
and complex
to the point where multiple programmers
tend to work on one project
in this case it's best if the section
that you are working on
is able to function without knowledge of
the inner workings of your colleagues
section
to achieve this it's best to think of
your program in terms of interface
and implementation the interface
refers to the ways that sections of code
are able to communicate with one another
this is typically done through methods
that each class is able to access
the exact implementation of these
methods or how the methods are coded
should be hidden within the class and
not accessible from the outside
think of this like the car the other
classes are able to turn the wheel
and push the gas and they know what the
outcome should be
without caring about exactly how this
gets done
let's return to the chess example that
we've been using throughout the video
let's say that you are working on making
the night work as it should
and a fellow programmer is working in
the king class
in order to effectively work together
you need to agree on an
interface with which these pieces are
able to communicate
in this case say that you are working on
making the knight
unable to move if your king is in check
as the programmer of the night class you
make the knight
use the king's getter method that will
let the knight know
whether or not the king is in check if
it
is then you make it so the knight is not
able to move
unless it is able to put the king out of
check
as you program the night class you
should not be concerned with how the
king is determining
whether or not it is in check the king's
method that tells the knight whether or
not
it is in check as part of the interface
but how exactly it does that
is part of the implementation this
manner
of only allowing the classes to interact
through a predetermined interface
prevents different pieces of the program
from becoming completely coupled
together
if the night class has to look into the
king class in order to make a
determination
then it is reliant on the king class
being set up in a certain way
in order to function if the king class
is changed or reorganized or its data is
renamed
then the night class would no longer
work and it too would have to be changed
assuming the rest of the program was
coded in this way
then many other classes would also have
to be modified
creating a set interface through which
classes can interact with one another
ensures that each individual piece can
be changed
without creating a ripple effect that
causes the entire program to have the
change in response
overall it's best to keep in mind
abstraction
when writing object-oriented code as it
allows the program to be worked on
incrementally
and prevents it from becoming completely
entangled in itself
and very complex determine specific
points of contact that can act as the
interface between classes
and only worry about the implementation
behind it when working on that section
this next section will be tackling
inheritance
the third of the main principles of
object-oriented programming
inheritance is the principle that allows
you to derive classes
from other classes classes can inherit
certain methods and attributes from
another class
we will get into exactly what this means
in a moment
but first let's look at an example
let's say you are programming a game in
this game
the player has access to weapons to
fight their enemies
to begin you may establish a weapons
class
this class would contain many of the
pertinent attributes and methods common
to weapons
for instance an attribute that
represents the damage that the weapon
deals
and a method that deals damage to an
opponent when called
you then would want some more clashes to
represent specific weapons
such as a sword or a club these classes
would act differently from one another
as swords and clubs have certain
different attributes
such as a sword being made for cutting
whereas a club is blunt
these differences would be represented
in different values for their attributes
as well as possibly different attributes
altogether
however they do share much of the same
behavior
as they are both members of the weapons
class
in this case the weapon class would be
the superclass
and the sword and club classes that
extend the weapon class
would be subclasses in relation to it
many of the attributes and methods
associated with the weapon class
would also be present in its subclasses
any given sword or club would also want
access to the methods that allow them to
deal damage
as well as the attributes that detail
how much and what type of damage they
deal
the class hierarchy does not tend to be
so small however
as in most cases there are many more
layers than just one superclass
and a couple of subclasses the weapon
class
may be a subclass to a broader items
class which could contain many other
subclasses
with subclasses of their own
additionally
you may include a wider variety of
weapons than just swords and clubs
as well as multiple types of swords that
would require different behaviors
and thus their own subclasses when you
are writing
object-oriented code many of the classes
you create
will fit somewhere in the broader class
hierarchy
which acts as a web of classes with
different relationships to one another
the next important topic to cover in
terms of inheritance
is the access modifiers that change
which classes access
which attributes methods or even classes
as a whole
there are three main access modifiers
that we will be discussing
public private and protected
let's begin with the public modifier
public is probably the most simple of
the modifiers
a public member or class can be accessed
from anywhere
this includes any super classes
subclasses
or anywhere else in the program this is
very useful
when you need to have access from a wide
variety of places in your program
to better understand this modifier and
those to come
look to the example class hierarchy on
screen that represents different foods
for each example the member in question
will be defined in the fruit class
green classes have access and red
classes do not
as you can see a public member being
defined in this class
or anywhere else can be accessed from
anywhere in your program
next we have the private modifier
private members can only be accessed
from within the same class
that the member is defined this is best
to use
if you do not need this information
accessed from anywhere else in the
program
additionally this allows you to create
other private members of the same name
in separate classes which will not
conflict with one another
due to their private access modifier
as you can see on the example class
hierarchy
a private member defined in the fruit
class can only be accessed inside the
fruit class
we then have the protected modifier a
protected variable
can be accessed from within the class it
is defined
as well as any subclasses of that class
essentially protected variables are
private to the class hierarchy that they
are defined
in this can be seen in the example class
hierarchy
right now
in this final section we will be
covering the final of the four main
principles
polymorphism polymorphism describes
methods that are able to take on
many forms there are two types of
polymorphism
the first one is what is called dynamic
dynamic polymorphism occurs during run
time
when the program is being executed
this describes when a method signature
is present in both a subclass
and a superclass the methods share the
same parameters
but have separate implementation in this
case
the subclasses implementation of the
method overrides the superclasses
let's go over an example let's say you
are writing a program
to represent many different types of
cars in a class hierarchy
at the top of the hierarchy you may have
the generic car
class you then may create a sports car
class as a subclass of the car class
you then may create a dot drive method
in both of the classes
in each of the classes the dot drive
function will take a double representing
the number of miles you would like the
car to drive
and the car's gas attribute will be
decreased by the pertinent amount
in the car class the dot drive function
may cause the car's gas to decrease by
0.04 gallons per mile
whereas the sports car class may instead
have its gas decreased
by 0.02 gallons per mile it drives
if you create an instance of a sports
car called my sports car
the sports car implementation of the dot
drive method will override the generic
car version of the dot drive method
therefore mysportscar.drive will
decrease my sports car's gas attribute
by 0.02 gallons per mile
however were you to create an instance
of the car class
called my car my car.drive
would instead decrease my car's gas by
0.04 gallons per mile this
is an example of dynamic polymorphism as
the implementation of a method signature
can change depending on which level in
the class hierarchy
that it is called this works this way
because the form of the method that is
called is decided dynamically
as the program is run this idea can be
extended across the class hierarchy
in more layers than just two you could
add more subclasses
representing different types of sports
cars with their own.drive methods
with different implementations and
creating an instance of each of these
subclasses
would use their own implementation of
the dot drive method
when call the main benefit
of dynamic polymorphism is that it
allows you to write methods in the
superclass without having to include
ifs and else shifts to account for
exactly which subclass
is being used when the method is called
the second type of polymorphism is
static polymorphism
static polymorphism occurs during
compile time
rather than runtime this refers to when
multiple methods
with the same name are defined in the
same class
in this case the methods are
differentiated by their arguments
either they take a different number of
parameters they take parameters of
different types
or they take parameters in a different
order than one another
this is known as method overloading
despite the names of the methods being
the same they have different method
signatures
due to their differences in the
parameters that they accept
to better understand this let's go back
to the car example
let's say that you are working within
the car class
in this class you are looking to create
three different drive methods
the first drive methods argument accepts
one integer
and one string as parameters say speed
and destination for clarity
we will refer to this one as drive
method one
however keep in mind that its method
name is just drive
for drive method 2 we will set its
argument to accept
two integers for instance distance and
speed
finally in drive method 3 we will have
it accept a string first for destination
and then an integer for speed
this differs from drive method 1 in that
drive method 1's parameters
are in reverse order compared to drive
method threes
in each of these three example methods
the method signature is different
despite the methods having the same name
therefore
the computer is able to tell the methods
apart when the program is being compiled
for example were i to call mycar.drive45
work drive method 1 would be called
as the argument given indicates that
this is the method
i would like to call furthermore
my car.drive 1560 would call drive
method 2
and mycall.drive school 30
would call drive method 3. when
implementing method overloading
the different methods tend to have
separate but similar effects
despite drive method 1 and drive method
3 taking the same parameters
it is likely that their implementation
would be different and thus would
achieve separate effects
otherwise there would be no reason to
have both methods
keep in mind that method overloading can
cause trouble
if you do not keep straight which of the
methods implementations you would like
to execute
and what form of the argument is
required to do so
normally if you call a method with too
many parameters
or parameters of the incorrect type then
the program will throw an error
and you will be able to fix the issue
however
if you mistake the methods argument in
such a way that one of the other methods
with the same name
is called instead then you may not even
be aware that you made a mistake
overall polymorphism simply allows
methods to take on many different forms
it can be very useful in that it allows
methods of the same name
to exist both in the same class and in
different classes
however you must be careful to ensure
that you are calling the correct form of
the method that you want
so your program can function as intended
that does it for polymorphism and with
the end of polymorphism
the final of the four main principles
comes the end of this video
on an introduction to object oriented
programming
if you enjoyed consider liking and
subscribing to null pointer exception
and check out some of our other videos
in which we cover a variety of other
topics that you may find helpful
thanks for watching